[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce set 8 les
invités une émission dédiée à celles et
ceux qui font l'actualité dont le
département aujourd'hui mercredi 4
janvier parole à marie christine le
tarnec la nouvelle maire socialiste de
guyancourt qui présentait ses premiers
voeux en qualité des deals l'occasion
pour elle de faire un point sur les
projets de la ville
et puis en plateau nous recevrons
nicolas souple et le co-fondateur de
squeeze une start-up yvelinoise qui vend
et confectionne des gourdes
réutilisables
c'est bon pour la planète c'est bon pour
le portefeuille et ses pratiques pour la
famille mais on débute donc avec cette
habitude des voeux chaque année les
maires des communes de saint quentin en
yvelines s'adressent à leurs populations
et aux différentes personnalités du
département et pour la première fois à
guyancourt c'est marie-christine le
tarnais qui s'est exprimé en tant que
maire de la ville c'était hier soir nous
sommes allés rencontrer celle qui a
succédé à françois de lumière en
décembre dernier on les couteaux micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude et wilfrid
richy première cérémonie de voeux avec
lui en cours pour la nouvelle maire
marie-christine le tarnec bonsoir
comment avez vous vécu cette première
cérémonie de voeux
c'était très agréable on est avec
l'ensemble des habitants qui viennent
effectivement passer un moment convivial
avec nous non non c'est un très très
beau moment très très bon moment c'est
particulier françois de ligne et qu'on a
souhaité rencontrer tout à leur préfère
lui se mettre en retrait il nous dit ce
n'est plus à moi de prendre la lumière
mais j'imagine que pour vous c'est quand
même un peu particulier de voir l'ancien
maire qui vous a passé la main il ya
quelques temps présent vous écouter
alors c'est avec des motions
effectivement il était à nos côtés
d'autres de trois fois je les regardais
c'était important qu'ils soient
effectivement nos côtés et
c'était un moment un moment très
particulier on se passe justement le
travail aujourd'hui vous avez pris
pleinement la mesure du poste est encore
un relais qui s'effectue l'équipe
municipale n'a pas changé vous l'avez
repréciser aussi sur scène non c'est
juste le nom du maire qui a changé mais
l'équipe c'est là même la direction
c'est la même
il ya eu une préparation assez
importante pour cette passation entre
françois de ligné et moi et bien c'est
la continuité
qu'attendre pour 2010 est pour lui un
coup on va en parler avec vous vous a
évoqué plusieurs projets on peut
peut-être tout d'abord commencer par
cette clinique qui va ouvrir dans les
prochaines semaines et qui signe un peu
le renouveau du quartier du pont du
rotois alors c'est pas le renouveau
c'est une continuité puisqu'il ya la
nouvelle école et allié des logements
qui se sont construits à résident home
et il ya effectivement celle cliniques
de soins de suite après il y aura une
résidence internationale et qui la
coulée verte aussi ça faisait partie
aussi des projets qui vont voir le jour
à partir de cette année pour les années
aussi qui vont arriver
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de jolis projets
sur notre vie sont les projets marquants
pour 2017 sur lui en cours alors il ya
le my des saules on à la réhabilitation
du mas des saules et à la clinique de
soins de suite à la maison
pluridisciplinaire de santé
et puis il ya aussi toutes les actions
que l'on fait au niveau des jeunes dont
la grande consultation jeunesse il va y
avoir une restitution
on va annoncer des projets qui ont été
demandés par les jeunes cet espace
jeunes aussi qui va être créée on va
commencer à y réfléchir cette année
et puis des quartiers qui bouge avec les
nouveaux logements carrier et puis à la
gare au sila la gare à la ryder cup
voilà beaucoup beaucoup de projets vous
avez beaucoup insisté sur le mélange des
générations la rencontre aussi la mixité
c'était un peu le fil rouge de votre
discours vous y tenait beaucoup à
guyancourt ses aiguilles en cours c'est
c'est comme ça effectivement que l'on
vit à guyancourt avec ensemble tous
ensemble
ville agréable à partager et c'est
important qu'on se soutienne tous les
uns les autres et qu'on vive là on vive
la même ville en ville et même film on
parle des dossiers des projets des
choses qui se porte bien dans la commune
ya des dossiers qui sont un peu plus
crispants je pense aux relations au sein
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
vous avez adressé un petit pic au cours
de votre discours sur le vote des
compétences notamment avec l exécutif de
la nouvelle majorité vous trouvez que
les choses vont trop vite aujourd'hui
alors les choses vont trop vite et ce
qui est intéressant pour nous c'est
qu'on veut absolument se faire respecter
et on veut avoir notre place aussi au
sein de la communauté d'agglomération
ont fait partie des douze communes ma
commune comme les autres les autres
communes de gauche et il a absolument
pas question de ne pas se faire
respecter ne pas avoir les mêmes droits
que les autres communes qui sont rentrés
dans l'est de respect quels sont les
points qui bloquent très clairement
pourquoi ce sentiment aujourd'hui et
bien d' entre autres pour les
compétences donc on a effectivement
rejeté lançons des compétences puisque
on pense qu'il ya encore du temps et
qu'on peut encore avoir des discussions
entre son nom puisqu'on n'est pas tous
d'accord sur les mêmes sujets et il faut
se laisser du temps puisque c'est
l'avenir de l'agglo qui se joue là et
pour nous il est important de prendre du
temps de laisser du temps pour continuer
à discuter à 12 solutions qui vont se
poursuivre j'imagine que vous appelez
aussi malgré les échéances électorales
vous appeler aussi de vos voeux à une
relation apaisée peut-être au sein de
l'agglomération complètement c'est ce
que j'ai dit aussi au président quand je
les rencontre et en tant que mère et je
lui ai dit que je souhaitais
effectivement des relations apaisées
en effet deux pas du même bord on sait
on sait très bien que l'agglo a changé
de mains mais on fait
on est une commune à part entière comme
les autres communes et on doit pouvoir
avoir de la possibilité de discuter de
se faire respecter
j'ai un des sujets qui concernent cette
fois ci la ville de huy encore que
j'aurais voulu aborder avec vous il ya
quelques semaines sont nos confrères du
parisien qui évoquait l'association
musulmans qui étaient hébergés ces
locaux étaient temporairement installés
dans un bus aujourd'hui quels sont les
rapports que vous entretenez avec
l'association alors la communauté
musulmane l'ensemble de la communauté
musulmane à un point effectivement à un
lieu pour pouvoir se réunir donc pour
nous il n'y a pas de souci il n'y a pas
de ses pas il n'y a pas de difficultés
puisque on met à la disposition de
l'ensemble de la communauté musulmane un
lieu pour qu'ils puissent se réunir
qu'ils puissent effectivement pratiquer
leur culte
donc il n'ya pas de souci pour nous tout
va bien vous qui vous échangez aussi
avec eux on échange avec la communauté
musulmane pas nécessairement avec
l'association on échange avec l'ensemble
de la communauté musulmane
un dernier mot 2010 cette année
électorale vous allez vous engager ou
pas alors pour l'instant ma priorité
c'est guyancourt pour l'instant et dans
les prochains mois pour l'instant ma
priorité c'est guyancourt on viendra
vous voir à cette occasion merci
beaucoup
on continue ce 7,8 les invités avec
notre invité plateau nicholas oublier
bonsoir bonsoir vous est le cofondateur
de squeeze une start pivi noise qui
confectionne et vend des gourdes
réutilisables
on va peut-être d'ailleurs montré une
tout de suite à l'écran lé sont juste
ici où on les verra plus tard mais en
tout cas ce sont des gourdes
réutilisables
on va présenter votre produit son idée
mais commencer peut-être d'abord par
nous raconter la genèse de cette
histoire qui a débuté en 2014 comment
vous est venue cette idée de créer ces
gourdes puisque c'est assez original
quand même cette île est en fait c'est
l'idée de deux parents de cinq enfants
mon épouse et moi-même qui sont partis
d'un constat c'est qu'effectivement nous
remplissions nous pouv elle est un petit
peu trop avec des gourdes jetables et
saviez-vous une claque en france chaque
année c'est plus de 600 millions de
gourdes jetables qui sont consommées est
jeté c'est énorme
donc on est parti de ce constat pour se
dire il ya peut-être moyen de faire un
petit peu mieux et de consommer de
manière plus responsable et c'est comme
ça qu'est née la squeeze
donc votre principal objectif est votre
principale motivation et écologiques
environnementales on économise combien
de gourdes quand on achète une gourde
squeeze par exemple les côtés avec une
avec une gourde ce quiz vous allez
pouvoir l'utiliser au minimum une
cinquantaine de fois donc cinquante fois
moins de déchets exactement
tout à fait expliquez-nous du coup
comment comment ça marche une bourde
quiz squeeze au louvre par où la gourde
squeeze ressemble beaucoup
j'adore de clairvaux rien à voir voilà
voilà exactement qu'elle ressemble
beaucoup avec une ouverture de ce
côté-là l'ouverture classique que vous
connaissez bien
sauf qu'en plus elle est équipée d'un
zip d'accord et c'est dans l'es6 qu'on
recharge
évidemment c'est par ici que s'effectue
le remplissage mais aussi le lavage
soirée puisque c est du coup assez
simple à nettoyer il faut peut-être
rentrer je ne sais pas l'épongé puis
alors en fait on peut la nettoyer soit
au lave-vaisselle soit avec un petit
roupillon un peu comme un biberon en
fait est d'accord la taille de la gourde
on peut mettre jusqu'à combien de il ya
plusieurs tailles
aujourd'hui on propose des gourdes de 90
mille litres et 130 mille litres alors
on voit aussi un design assez drôle ça
peut aussi peut-être aider les plus
jeunes à boire ou à manger des aliments
qui n'aiment pas qu'il n'apprécie pas sa
peine et c'est un argument exactement on
s'est dit en fait comme vous donner le
choix aux parents de mettre ce qu'ils
voulaient à l'intérieur des squeeze que
ce soit de la purée de la compote de
yaoundé ce maudit finalement derrière
ces gourdes sont adaptés à tous types de
publics et donc on peut les rendre
beaucoup plus fun on n'est pas obligé
simplement de mettre des pommes dessus
donc on a fait des design aussi bien
pour les enfants que des designs pour
les bébés mais aussi on a des designs
voyait adultes voidray autre information
pratique j'ai vu un instant que ici on y
avait comme un espace pour écrire oui
c'est pour dire ce qui à l'intérieur
soit pour écrire effectivement le
contenu soit pour y mettre le prénom de
l'enfant par exemple c'est une invention
enfin c'est votre invention européennes
mais elle vient à la base je crois des
états unis c'est ça alors à mes
franco-américain est exactement
et c'est une inspiration qui vient de
vous deux
exactement alors il y avait
effectivement une idée qui avait été
développé aux états unis un peu sur le
même principe mais par contre avec un
business model vraiment complètement
différent en particulier avec de la
production en chine
or quand nous avons créé les squeeze
nous avions vraiment la volonté de créer
d'avoir un impact positif aussi bien sur
l'environnement que sur nos clients nos
employés nos fournisseurs et les
communautés dans lesquelles on vit et on
s'est dit dès le départ on veut produire
en europe et 500 européens aujourd'hui
exactement et si possible au plus près
de verneuil sur seine où sont nos locaux
à projets européens et yvelinois
aujourd'hui vous êtes lancée en 2014
c'est une affaire qui marche
est-ce que vous avez des difficultés à
vous insérer sur le marché ou alors
c'est une affaire qui qui commence à
rouler avec le temps mais écoutez son et
on est encore très jeune puisque on a
deux ans et demi mais on peut être fier
d'avoir vendu plus de 400 mille gourdes
en qu'en deux ans de commercialisation
quatre cent mille gourdes ça fait x 50
ça fait tout ça aussi d'économiser
d'actes mans donc on est on peut on
pourrait dire 20 milliards de la
calculer là tout de suite mais ça fait
beaucoup 20 millions de gourdes jetables
la cie économiser on peut dire ça oui
oui tout à fait alors on vous trouve en
france mais pas que puisque vous le
disiez projet européen on vous trouve
par exemple j'ai fouillé un peu sur le
site internet aux pays-bas en suisse en
belgique
exactement principalement en europe dans
plus de 15 pays européens pour les
consommateurs français
ceux qui sont intéressés qui veulent
avoir plus d'information savoir où on
peut les acheter d'autres informations
complémentaires
on se rend ou sur l'internet on peut
aussi se rendre dans des commerces
bien sûr sans forcément les nommer bien
sûr sans forcément est nommé alors on
peut nous trouver dans des réseaux bio
on peut les trouver dans les magasins de
puériculture dans les magasins d'arts de
la table et même dans des pharmacies
on est aussi effectivement sur internet
il suffit de taper ce quiz dans les
moteurs de recherche
un mot enfin pour sur le prix de ce quiz
une gourde asquith ça coûte combien
aujourd'hui donc cesser
lot 2 go en fait ces gourdes sont vendus
par lots et sur un lot de 3 par exemple
on est à un peu moins de 15 euros
d'accord donc si on achète ça pour le
début 2017 c'est une bonne résolution de
résolutions écologiques
environnementales r on la conseille oui
exactement et économique vous le disiez
économique et mercy elle nicolas soulet
d'être venu sur notre plateau vous êtes
je le rappelle le cofondateur de squeeze
la gourdes réutilisables made in est
yvelines c'est la fin du set 8 les
invités pour ce soir prochain rendez
vous demain à 5 janvier
excellente soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]